yeah i remember when i first learned
about the principle
uh can you just introduce yourself real
quick my name is dan olson i am the
writer and director of in search of a
flat earth
i first became aware of the principle
when i was working on a documentary
about
flat earth philosophy there was this
particular flat earth channel on youtube
and i was going through
all the most watched videos on the
channel taking notes and
one of them this two hour video
had just these long long clips from some
other documentary about copernicus and
kepler and brahe
and it was actually kind of decent
quality animation and
kate mulgrew was narrating and it said
on screen
explicitly used with permission such and
such films
and i thought you know that's odd the
greatest astronomer of the time
tico brahe developed a new geocentric
model
the earth occupies the center the
planets
orbit the sun and the sun orbits the
earth
you know youtube culture being what it
is it's already unusual for
anyone to actually ask permission let
alone
on flat earth youtube so right away
that told me that something was up
clearly
the people who made this first video
which
was just an anti-science screed
on a channel full of flat earth
anti-backs ancient alien stuff
clearly all of these people were on the
same wavelength and that's weird there's
not
usually a lot of crossover between
random youtube cranks and the kind of
people
who are able to get in touch with kate
mulgrew's agent
so i prod a bit and it turns out there's
a whole
buck wild story behind that it had
actually made a small splash when the
film first came out in i think it was
2014.
you know this this documentary about how
earth is the center of the universe and
the sun revol like orbits the earth and
they tricked a bunch of astrophysicists
into being in it and and
kate mulder was narrating and there's
this whole
story behind that and i just knew that
it
was something that i might want to talk
about
but then as i was digging a bit deeper
i realized that the executive producer
robertson jennis
a man with a doctorate degree
from a fake university effectively
interviewed himself
in his own movie in order to make
himself look like an expert
and and it was just like that's it
that's it i
i have to talk about this now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay first things first the earth is not
the center of the universe i'm putting
this at the front because i
don't want to have to debunk every
random ass claim the filmmakers toss out
as they come
up the folks who made this film are
going to make a number of claims that
are just wrong we have in fact
demonstrated that the earth orbits the
sun stellar parallax was first measured
in the 1830s and has only gotten
more precise since and lagrange point
satellites behave the way that they do
because we accurately understand how
gravity behaves on celestial objects
an understanding that has enabled us to
for example detect black holes as in
this
23-year time lapse of s2 orbiting the
black hole
sagittarius a the central claim of the
film is that the cosmic microwave
background radiation indicates that the
earth is the center
of a universal axis which is just not
actually true they massage the data to
make it look more significant than it
really is
giving the misleading impression that
it's a very precise
axis that passes right through the earth
but in
reality it's a lot more vague than that
bottom line geocentrism as a model of
the cosmos
requires a universe where a series of
incredibly consistent physical
principles apply to
everything else we can see except
us now that's exactly what they're
trying to imply
but as with flat earth this creates a
cascade effect where successively
more and more functional predictive
science needs to be discarded
in order to make the claim work you
can't just redraw the orbits of the
solar system
you need to claim the earth is
gravitationally
exceptional and if earth is the fulcrum
of the universe then the stellar field
needs to be moving
at absurd speeds in order to orbit the
earth once every 24 hours
speeds that would be detectable and
relativistic
and so you also need to discard
relativity and
it all just causes a cascade and again
that right there
is exactly what they're claiming that
they found evidence that
should cause us to toss out relativity
and universal gravity and everything
we've discovered based on those
principles
because it disagrees with their model
and since that
isn't happening they claim there's a
conspiracy
that's suppressing the evidence and now
on with the show
in the spring of 2014 a small media
storm kicked up around the trailer for
an upcoming documentary written by rick
delano directed by katherine thomas and
produced by robert syngenis
the trailer narrated by star trek
voyagers kate mulgrew and featuring
a number of high-profile physicists
including lawrence krauss max tegmark
and michio kaku
seems to be arguing against the
heliocentric model of the solar system
everything we think we know about our
universe
is wrong you can go on some websites of
nasa and see that they've started to
take down stuff
that might hint to a geocentric universe
so they set up the satellite and they
find out these temperature disturbances
throughout the universe were all
pointing to the earth
this caught the attention of a bunch of
entertainment industry publications
which led to several of the participants
issuing
public denunciations of their role in
the film lawrence krauss wrote an
article for slate titled
i have no idea how i ended up in that
stupid geocentrism documentary
i have no recollection of being
interviewed for such a film and of
course had i known of its premise i
would have refused
so either the producers used clips of me
that were in the public domain
or they bought them from other
production companies that i may have
given some rights to distribute my
interviews to
or they may have interviewed me under
false pretenses in which case i probably
signed some release
following kraus's lead kate mulgrew
issued a short statement on facebook
i understand there has been some
controversy about my participation in a
documentary called the principle
let me assure everyone that i completely
agree with the eminent physicist
lawrence krauss
who was himself misrepresented in the
film and who has written a succinct
rebuttal in slate i am not a geocentrist
nor am i
in any way a proponent of geocentrism
more importantly
i do not subscribe to anything robert
sungenus has written regarding science
and history and
had i known of his involvement would
most certainly have avoided this
documentary
i was a voice for hire and a misinformed
one at that i apologize for any
confusion that my voice on this trailer
may have caused the producers fired back
against these by posting a youtube video
hosted by
writer producer rick delano titled
thought crime the conspiracy to stop the
principle
which you know jesus christ
thought crime conspiracy i i think that
alone
gives you a pretty good snapshot of
where these folks are at
in this video that implies they are the
target of a conspiracy they provide what
they consider to be discrediting
evidence against kraus and mulgrew
and explicitly state that it's not about
geocentrism
it's about cosmology i checked the film
thousands and thousands and thousands of
time and there's just nothing about the
jews in the film
it just isn't it's film about cosmology
it's a film about the copernican
principle this is a sentiment he has
expressed repeatedly
in an interview with colin lescher at
popular science
the film is not about geocentrism delano
told me flatly
rather it's about the copernican
principle copernicus's idea that the
earth doesn't occupy a cosmically
special place in the universe
okay first of all those aren't mutually
exclusive
those are nested subjects second is the
movie geocentric
sort of rick's wishy-washy
it's not about geocentrism it's about
cosmology
is actually pretty accurate to the
finished movie in that the film
shares that wishy-washy attitude the
film itself is a lot more
non-committal than the trailer implies
being mostly composed of implication in
innuendo
rather than offering any actual claims
so what i take away from this is we
simply always need to keep an open mind
and
listen to all viewpoints and let mother
nature be the
one who gets the final word there's
always a revolution coming in science
because science is necessarily
provisional it cannot make a final
statement because
it doesn't know everything it cannot
examine what's going on at the four
corners of the universe
as to how many angels dance on the head
of a pin
i think it's still an open question you
know i could tell you
what the future might be but but it
could be something different
there's not a lot to really sum up about
the documentary itself
the a plot is mostly interviews with a
mix of scientists and crackpot religious
zealots while the b plot is a reasonably
accurate animated summary of the
development
of the solar model from prehistory to
albert einstein
just with the occasional curiosity of
how something is framed that
tosses up the odd red flag here and
there this is the beginning of
faith and the beginning of science
in the beginning they're both the same
thing and that's kind of the crux of it
there's no screamingly absurd claims
this isn't masaru emoto claiming you can
grant
water healing properties by exposing it
to positive thoughts
[Music]
even when the film gets into theology it
does so in a really
tepid vague way talking mostly about
faith in the abstract ever since the
trial of galileo
there has often been tension if not
outright conflict
between faith and science remarkably
the copernican principle seems to be the
ground upon which
faith and science are again at long last
approaching one another as a whole the
principle is an adept example of a
classic form of bad faith debate
which is the school of just asking
questions
it's a form of debate where you advance
your ideological agenda entirely in the
form of questions in order to take the
role of a non-committed bystander
who doesn't believe anything and has no
opinions but has a lot of concerns
this approach becomes fairly obvious
when you listen to the way that sun
genus and delano and thomas defend the
film
focusing mostly on a narrative that the
principle is
exploring possibilities and the
particular idea
that the pre-emptive critics of the film
were misled by the film's trailer
okay so they did see the trailer and i
think all these conclusions are being
made yeah that's true
they're basing it off the trailer but
when you actually watch the film
people come back and go that's not what
was in the news
of course that's all deliberate the
trailer is intentionally provocative
like i can't really think of a clearer
example of bad faith whinging than this
and the trailer of course is a trailer
it's designed to stir up controversy
and uh you know we just assumed that
we'd get the same treatment as everybody
else which is foolish assumption
rick rick you made the trailer
it's your trailer for your movie you
don't get to complain that the trailer
misled people when you're the person who
made the trailer
but this does create a really
entertaining contrast between the movie
itself and all the paratextual things
that the creators put
out so on one hand the director
catherine thomas
claims that the movie is a really
even-handed examination of some
cutting-edge science
where everyone gets an equal say and
it's left to the audience to draw their
own conclusions
and another thing about it was making
sure that it was balanced
which of course you know the controversy
came out saying that it wasn't but
it's truly you know my i even said when
i did this
i said hey listen if we're going to make
a film that's one-sided i'm no i don't
want to be involved but if we're gonna
if we're gonna let everybody have a seat
at the table and then let
you know the audience figure out what
they want to do then i'm all in
and so that's that's what you did so
beautifully
and on the other hand you have the
second
trailer for the film science has found
evidence
that earth is the center of the universe
science has found evidence that god
exists
so why do they tell us we are
insignificant
not to mention you know robertson jennis
the executive producer who has
continued to be heavily involved in the
promotion of the film for
years following its release including
writing numerous
commentary articles for the official
website theprincipalmovie.com
wrote an entire book promoting
geocentrism
called galileo was wrong the church was
right
now you might be wondering if maybe
that's also just some provocative
marketing
maybe it's just a way to reel people in
for a discussion of some interesting
oddities in data derived from
measurements of the cosmic microwave
background radiation
chapter 3 evidence earth is in the
center of the universe
okay yeah that's pretty unambiguous and
this is the root of it
despite the superficially non-committal
just asking questions tone of the film
the intended takeaway is pretty obvious
and is of course
reinforced by the evidence of how the
film has been rhetorically employed
since its release
with the film mostly playing for
christian faith film audiences
and the same new age spirituality crowd
as other pseudo-science and
lightly conspiratorial films like what
the bleep do we know and zeitgeist
[Music]
before we go on let's talk for a bit
about the folks behind it all because to
really understand what the principal is
saying
we need to understand the world view
that it comes from so two people we've
already partly introduced writer
producer rick delano and
director editor catherine thomas they
are the frontline filmmakers
thomas a music video producer and
director turned documentarian
seems to have fallen in with delano by
happenstance
and while she claims she disagrees with
rick about a lot of stuff
the two of them have continued to work
together since and she vocally defends
the film
if you give an opinion where a
geocentric opinion from once
one subject and they go oh no no no you
can't say that you know
and if you go oh and like the principle
you have multiverse you have string
theory you have
all of this and i'm like all of this is
controversial and
and actually that's what kind of made me
mad whenever i was seeing
what when people were attacking the
principle they were only attacking one
thing which was the geocentric stuff and
i was like why
because there's so many theories in here
delano is a catholic fundamentalist and
seemingly a true believer in geocentrism
for years prior to the production of the
principal rick maintained a personal
blog titled magisterial fundies
from the october 2011 launch post of
that blog
magisterial fundes the soft opening rick
states
the catholic church has by the sovereign
decision of god almighty
being granted a charism to teach the
truth concerning faith and morals
infallibly
i expect to examine precisely those
anomalous unusual cases where
magisterial teaching has either been
abandoned
or qualified by subsequent lower level
teaching
critical areas will include 1. the
question of whether the jews enjoy a
separate covenant for salvation
i argue that this notion is damnable
heresy
2 whether the church has reversed her
condemnation of galileo
i argue she hasn't and i further argue
that the utterly astounding new
observations from
sdss and wmap suggest that this
is an extraordinarily powerful instance
where the protection of the church's
teaching
on geocentrism is being validated before
our eyes by science itself
400 years after the fact on top of this
rick is
absolutely conspiratorially minded
tossing out
bizarre accusations and claims as though
they're
self-evident we had no chance with the
principle against the forces that were
arraigned against us we were just
you know we were targeted for
destruction and absolute and we had the
highest grossing single screen opening
in america
the weekend that we opened and they
wouldn't even hold us over in the
theater because we were the subject of a
boycott by a political organization
executive producer robert sengenus has a
doctorate in religious studies from
calamus international university
with the hitch being that calamus
international university is a defunct
unaccredited distance learning outfit
that was registered in the republic of
venuatu
but consisted entirely of a po box and a
secretary service in
london his doctoral work in religious
studies
was overseen mainly by two people by a
physicist
robert bennett who is also the co-author
of syngenesis book galileo was wrong
and is in the principal and dr morris
berg now berg's an interesting guy dr
berg has a bachelor of science in
psychology from the university of east
london
and then phd and dch degrees
in hypnotherapy from quote
overseas universities he's also an
accredited past life healer
registered metaphysician and an energy
eft master practitioner certified by the
guild of energists
okay so let's just have a look at the
modern energy chart
this is a pictorial representation
of a pattern that exists
at least and i mean at least in all
social mammals
the guild of energists are one of those
kind of really predictable self-help
systems that takes a couple reasonable
ideas
like happiness is good and maps it onto
a truly bonkers series of metaphysics
and
once you scratch the surface you realize
it's just
the secret or prosperity gospel or the
power of positive thinking
including the same dangerous core belief
that good people are successful
therefore
successful people are good and of course
it gets a little bit culty when you get
into the parts where the founder
sylvia hartman starts talking about
coming out of the energy closet
this is just completely not surprising
at all it's crank magnetism
people with fake credentials get their
fake credentials from other people with
fake
credentials there's an entire ecosystem
of these kinds of grifters
folks with questionable credentials who
are adopting
a fundamentally anti-science stance but
do so by claiming that they have the
real science
they are absurdly common in self-help
dieting and alternative medicine but
as we see here the more mathematical
sciences
are hardly immune okay so those are just
some of the folks that robert sungenis
hangs out with
in addition to his fake degree robert is
a trad cath or
traditionalist catholic which is a term
that we should dig
a little deeper into in casual modern
use tradcath tends to just refer to a
particularly conservative strain of
catholic thinker
but robert is a bit more of a
traditional trad cath
which means he airs a lot more towards
the philosophical roots of the term
which is rooted in opposition to the
second vatican council
aka vatican ii held between 1959 and
1965
this was a series of formal debates
within the catholic church
in direct response to a number of
internal and external pressures
such as the growing civil rights
movement in america women's liberation
declining church attendance the
evangelical
non-denominational movement and growing
criticism and scrutiny
it was in short an attempt at
modernizing the church
these sessions resulted in a number of
substantial changes to church operations
general policy logistical changes and
official redefinition of the
relationship between the church
and various social groups among the more
obvious and dramatic changes were that
it became formally permitted for mass to
be administered in a language that
wasn't latin a policy called vernacular
mass
and encouraged a greater emphasis on lay
participation
rather than strict clerical dispensation
this means
one getting general congregants more
involved in weekly services
and two actually performing mass in the
language that the congregation speaks
this is also when the church formally
changed its opinion on the death of
jesus
stating true the jewish authorities and
those who followed their lead
pressed for the death of christ still
what happened in his passion cannot be
charged against
all the jews without distinction then
alive
nor against the jews of today although
the church is the new people of god
the jews should not be presented as
rejected or accursed by god
so they no longer held all jews
categorically responsible for the death
of jesus
which they previously had for hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of years i
guess better late
than never the last change i want to
mention was the church pivoting its view
on non-catholic christian denominations
reverting the anti-reformation council
of trent
viewing protestants and the eastern
orthodox tradition specifically
as separated brethren rather than
heretics
this is a subtle but important policy
change because it effectively signaled
that the various
traditionalist denominations shared
common political interests
and it would be more important to
cooperate on those fronts
than hold on to old sectarian grudges
but
in doing so the church ceded its
absolute stance of supreme authority
so this is complicated vatican ii is in
some regards progressive but
only as progressive as needed to retain
membership
and improve political relations with
other conservative organizations
so imagine the kind of person who thinks
it was going too far
now in all fairness saint genus has
stated in a 2005
article for catholic paper the new
oxford review we must accept
vatican ii as a legitimate ecumenical
council without dogmatic error
and designed for the good of the church
in reality ninety-five percent of its
words are unproblematic
if the other five percent is interpreted
in the light of tradition
rather than liberalism and neo-modernism
we shouldn't have too much problem
ironing out any difficulties so he
doesn't reject it categorically or even
have much complaint with the vast
majority of the actual contents
what he does have problems with is that
issue of supreme authority
just when we needed a strong hand to
remind us of our moral obligations in
the midst of a world gone crazy with the
lust for power
eg world wars 1 and 2 and a world either
contemplating or actually indulging in
some of its worst sins
eg contraception abortion divorce
promiscuity homosexuality
the prelates of vatican ii more or less
forgot
why the traditional church through her
regimen of strong laws and purifying
disciplines
insisted on keeping tight reigns on her
people
this is why liberalism will never work
on this earth
its utopian ideals ignore the fact that
deep within man there is a sin
problem that simply won't go away by
wishful thinking
keep in mind that when he says
liberalism in this context he's talking
about like
john locke and thomas hobbes
he means democracy he's saying democracy
will never work
so one of the main things that people
praise vatican 2 for
creating sanctioned room within the
church for liberation theology and thus
the likes of oscar romero
that's the stuff he really takes issue
with
this brings me to one of roberts and
genus's other friends and fellow the
principal participant
martin selbreed i'm going to warn you
this guy is a huge piece of garbage with
some
truly repugnant beliefs this does get a
bit heavy
this is martin selbred a geocentrist and
theologian he has advocated for a
geocentric model for
years both within fundamentalist
christian circles
as a companion to creationism and
externally in debates with the actual
scientific community
martin is the vice president of the
chalcedon foundation
a christian reconstructionist think tank
dedicated to lobbying for
laws that conform to their
interpretation
of biblical laws this manifests
practically in two
forms the first of these is a specific
form of libertarianism
that philosophically is opposed to large
nation states
but in the short term manifests in the
push for extremely permissive
homeschooling standards
which i mean martin here is in a
documentary arguing that the earth is
the center of the universe
so you can probably imagine what the
curriculum looks like
also they stand in opposition to like
anti-discrimination laws that prevent
employers from
firing people for being trans the second
expression is an explicit push for
returning things to the
natural order enshrining christian
supremacy and eliminating the separation
of church and state
now a number of people have posited that
this extreme position means the
chalcedon foundation supports policies
like
the death penalty as a punishment for
homosexuality
and indeed the southern poverty law
center lists the chalcedon foundation as
a hate group
for exactly that reason in response to
these accusations the chalcedon
foundation plays a little rhetorical
game where they deflect by repeatedly
saying
they support biblical law it's a way of
pretending to deny something without
denying it but it's also a way of
confirming something without having to
actually say it out loud
celebrate in a 2007 article titled
answering tough questions about
christian reconstruction
frames it like this decade after decade
as a nation grows more biblically
consistent and an ever-increasing
percentage of its population regards the
law of god
as the proper standard of morality it is
likely the resulting social pressures
now so successfully applied via our
current culture of political correctness
would gradually revert back in favor of
biblical moral expectations
causing most biblically illicit conduct
to seek more private venues
beyond the reach of eyewitnesses to the
act well before
any such biblical laws became
transcribed into civil law
the idea of some kind of wholesale
slaughter of
say homosexuals is a total fabrication
resting on a fragmentary piecemeal
unsystematized approach to biblical law
biblical law deals with concrete acts
observed by
qualified eyewitnesses translated he
does support the state-sanctioned murder
of homosexuals
but only as long as it's systematized
and he claims it wouldn't matter anyway
you wouldn't actually get that many
executions
because all of the overt social
hostility towards homosexuality would
drive all of the gays back into the
closet
long before you could even make
homosexuality illegal
let alone a capital offense remember
that libertarianism
yeah they oppose large nation states
like the usa
because they believe that large nations
will inevitably be multicultural
purely as a consequence of encompassing
large numbers of people
across large geographic areas which
provides the opportunity
for minority cultures to find common
cause unite and push for their
interests thus smaller local
christian hegemons are better equipped
to enforce biblical law
and keep the underclass suppressed fun
stuff
these guys are the philosophical core of
the principle and the rest of the film
is structured to make it look
like all these scientists really
secretly agree with them
[Music]
can i just say that this setup for
lawrence krauss's interview with this
green edge light
that it's hideous i get the intent but
it looks it looks gross
and no one else is lit like that
anyway one of the reasons why i wanted
to talk about the principle is because
the film itself isn't entirely
incompetent
it's a pretty good example of how the
narrative language of documentary can be
utilized rhetorically
because the entire foundation of the
film is to make a discredited idea
seem not just plausible but supported
and to do that you need to launder a few
things
so this is how you scrub the ideas you
don't say
we're making a movie proving that the
earth is the center of the universe
you say we're making a movie about
changes in our understanding of the
copernican principle
or we're making a movie about the
history and
future of cosmology there's just nothing
about the jews in the film it just isn't
it's
film about cosmology it's a film about
the copernican principle
it's not wrong you haven't lied you've
just
omitted a conclusion that you know
participants will disagree with
you don't do a total hack job where you
cut up what people are saying to make
them
say the opposite of what they meant i
noticed she was sitting on her
we can i grab her sweetie can oh
you use framing and juxtaposition the
kuleshov effect
to manufacture consensus you take two
scientists
and in between them you sandwich a guy
with a fake doctorate who wrote a book
called galileo was wrong
technically speaking you don't take any
of the three
out of context you aren't lifting razor
thin
sound bites but all three are energized
excited
and seemingly in agreement with each
other
this is a fine line you haven't made
anyone say
something they didn't you've just
created the appearance
that they support ideas that they don't
it's a form of misrepresentation that's
exhausting to litigate
and honestly isn't worth it beyond like
writing an op-ed or putting out some
mean tweets
that's why no one who was involved who
spoke out against the film
took it any farther than just mean
tweets
what's interesting to me is that the
filmmakers have a narrative that they're
trying to work
and have continued to work even after
the film's release
one of the things the film suggests with
a
wink and a nudge is the outline of a
conspiracy that is
actively suppressing this information
all i have to do to shut up geocentrist
is to run this
experiment upon the moon and see what's
going to happen
and all of physics collapses with that
experiment i think there's a reason not
to put the experiment on the moon
albert einstein himself said that
if michelson morley is wrong
then relativity is wrong it implies that
all these scientists
really do agree that the prevailing
evidence suggests
a geocentric world but they can't speak
plainly about it
because they would be ostracized from
the scientific community
lose their jobs lose access to grant
money and generally throw a huge wrench
into their own lives
if one day god comes down from above and
says
look these two great theories relativity
and the quantum theory
are wrong what would i say
first of all i would say oh my god all
my published works are wrong
i mean i'll have to look for another job
this also lets the filmmakers frame
themselves as doing the interviewees a
favor
by leaving it as innuendo and that in
turn
builds a sense of intrigue that this is
a view that's so taboo
we dare not even say its name we've
clearly touched a nerve
we're clearly questioning something that
some very
powerful people are uncomfortable having
questions that's absolutely
also can we talk for a moment about the
absurdity of a bunch of
catholics claiming that their
cosmological model is being suppressed
by some
nebulous group so after the trailer for
the film comes
out a number of the participants issued
statements basically saying they had no
idea what the scope of the project was
they were presented out of context they
don't remember being interviewed for a
pro-geo-centric documentary the
filmmakers counter by posting a response
video to youtube
and this is where they continue that
little sleight of hand
trick from earlier in the response video
they include
extended clips of some interviews some
behind the scenes footage
and a copy of kraus's image release form
lawrence krauss
signed a release form here it is yeah
there's been
all the releases 400 news articles
saying that it doesn't exist yet that
last one is
a real trick in presenting the image
release forms they're submitting
evidence for one thing and implying
it's evidence of another see the signed
release
does prove that kraus signed a release
with stellar motion pictures
incorporated
but it doesn't prove that the
interviewers were
forthright with the underlying motives
of the production
there's been a lot of all the releases
400 news articles saying that it doesn't
exist yes it exists
let's show it real quick yes it does
tell him that we're going to be seeking
out controversial it's the same release
everybody else
everybody can yeah your lawyers made it
up there's no multiple releases it's
very clear
nothing in this bog standard release
says
this movie is going to be
anti-copernican anti-galilean
pro-geo-centric that informed consent
is merely implied and again rick is
highly susceptible to conspiratorial
thinking
so he just leaves it assumed as though
it's self-evidently obvious
that there's an organized conspiracy to
stop them
he had no chance with the principle
against the forces that were arrayed
against us we were just
funny enough by posting all this stuff
in the thought crime follow-up video
they actually give us a really good
insight into how you go about
tricking a bunch of physicists into
being in a geocentric documentary
in an extended clip of max tegmark being
interviewed by delano they
show us the kinds of questions that they
were asking
also keep in mind that this footage is
being presented
to support the argument that rick delano
did not disguise the subject or
intent of the film let me read a quote
another quote from professor krauss yeah
and just get and then we can move on
from this particular aspect because
the centrality of earth and the customer
microwave background is a fascinating
yeah it could be a mistake it could be a
glitch but there are other elements that
are pointing in the same direction now
kraus says professor cross says when you
look at the cmb map you see that the
structure that is observed is in fact
in fact in a weird way correlated with
the plane of the earth around the sun
is this copernicus coming back to haunt
us
that's crazy we're looking out at the
whole universe there's no way there
should be a correlation of structure
with our emotion of the earth around the
sun the plane of the earth and the sun
the ecliptic
that would say we are truly the center
of the universe would you agree with
that assessment
[Laughter]
okay so there's a couple things
happening here first of all
that question was 162 words long
it's a lot of rambling it's a lot of
overlapping ideas and then the core of
it is framed not as a question from the
filmmakers
but as an opportunity to respond to
something professor krauss said
let me read a quote another quote from
professor kraus see there's a big big
difference between
asking someone if earth is the center of
the universe
and asking them to reply to a colleague
the second is a lot more likely to get a
much more
diplomatic measured response where they
don't
openly disagree but instead suggests
that you know
maybe they were just talking really fast
and didn't word their ideas the best or
maybe the data has some nuance that's
difficult to explain
or are there some additional controls
that need to be implemented into testing
would you agree with that assessment
i don't think that this is telling us
that earth is in any way
the center of the universe and that kind
of overly cautious response
is how you get the kind of replies that
you can use
to construct consensus if you just give
a listen i think it'll
make it quite clear that we were very
upfront about what we were talking about
documentary operates off the assumption
of good faith
we go into a documentary willing to
believe that the filmmakers are
communicating
at the very least the essence of the
truth
a lot of these editing techniques or
even just techniques in general
are really conventional like juxtaposing
several speakers in sequence
it's a very normal way to communicate
consensus
and it's not misleading if the three
people agreeing with each other
actually agree with each other it's not
bad form to ask participants to respond
to statements made by other participants
it's a very
normal thing to do as you're building
the narrative of the documentary
and is a very normal way to go about
getting clear
focused answers when illustrating
disagreements on a subject
in that regard the principle is an
excellent cautionary tale
a reminder to always keep in the back of
your head
the documentary will never be the entire
story
[Music]
okay so i think the outstanding question
here is
why geocentrism delino has been blogging
about the idea
for years sungenis has written multiple
books and tracks trying to push the
geocentric model
martin cellbreed has been arguing for
geocentrism since the 90s
heck robert has even gone to flat earth
conferences
to argue that they're wrong about the
shape of the earth
but write about its position in the
universe
the topic of this debate is biblical
cosmology
[Music]
what does the bible have to say about
the shape and nature of the earth
and its place in the cosmos they are
trying to be the thin
end of the wedge both in the sense of
creating the appearance
of wide support for their ideas and in
the sense that the
subsequent ideas that naturally follow
from the conclusions
presented in the principle lead directly
into their trad cath dominionist
theology
quick aside mainstream biblical scholars
largely agree that the biblical
cosmology is neither heliocentric
nor geocentric but is poetic
with cosmological statements being
metaphors meant to communicate spiritual
ideas
ancient people had stories and theater
and understood the idea of myth and
legend
ancient audiences would have understood
phrases like
the pillars of the earth as poetic
metaphor
and would find it weird if you insisted
that it needed to be literal
because moses wrote genesis chapter one
he wrote it around 1400 bc
and he was inspired by god to do so and
inspired means that it's inerrant
and it tells us the exact truth of what
went on so the task for the scholar
is not to undermine the text and wish it
away
as if it never existed his task is to
see
what does this mean and how does it
apply
to what i know today the train of
thought is that geocentrism proves not
just a biblical universe
but one of rigid hierarchy a phrase that
the film repeatedly fixates on
is the idea that the earth isn't in any
specially favored
or central location the copernican
principle
named after nicholas copernicus states
that the earth is not in any specially
favored or central location
so how could we possibly be significant
but i've really completely changed my
mind and now i actually think
we're very significant and so at the end
of the day
the question remains are we significant
or just a cosmic accident to get away
from that copernican principle and the
notion that man
means nothing from just a meaningless
molecule to a human being
that's in a special location for
presumably a special purpose
the earth is a very special place no two
ways about it
so why do they tell us we are
insignificant
they really chafe against this phrase
they really don't like the idea
that something might be abstract or
relative
they're absolutists and they want to
impose that absolutism
on the universe itself their entire idea
is that earth needs to be located
somewhere special
in order to be meaningful it's the same
kind of thinking that says
important people are born in important
places and
important places are important for
metaphysical reasons
rome is not important because of the
people who live there
but the people are important because
they come from rome
to illustrate this delano has a very
strange hypothetical that he uses to try
and express
his existential anxiety now think about
this for a second
if you believe that there is no actual
standard by which you can say something
is solid
and not moving and at rest and a basis
for which to make
measurements well you're going to have
another kind of civilization
a hundred years ago you know if i would
have said to you
jay that's your reality dude
you would have called the psycho ward i
mean what do you mean that's your
reality dude
i am sure alex that at some point in
your life
you have encountered someone who has
said to you
at some point under some set of
circumstances something along the lines
of
dude that's your reality
right you've heard that right
yeah but you're not getting to the point
of what i'm talking about this is a man
who seems to fully believe
that the existence of multiple universes
would lead to a
total breakdown in society as
nothing would be knowable and thus you
would no longer be able to hold
anyone to account for anything they did
because
like what is anything man
of course this is all ultimately just
cultural
delanos and genus and celery are
terrified of the other
they believe that they are of a superior
type of person
and are rightfully owed dominion over
sinners degenerates and lesser people
if the earth is in a fixed position
dominant over the sun and stars
then god put it there and gave it that
prominence and if god put the earth in
place then god also put the church in
place and likewise gave it position
and dominance and authority but you know
they're wrong they're a bunch of dumb
asses with fake degrees they bought from
their hypnotherapist friends
all right hit me uh the earth gay the
moon
lesbian mercury straight venus
come on bye obvi mars
also buy but almost exclusively dates
men jupiter
asked he'll say straight but
he also sleeps with everything and i
mean
you know um you know i think it's
important that we give people space
the galilean moons pan polycule uh
except callisto who is monogamous with
ganymede
saturn straight but a huge ally ever
since titan came out of the closet
neptune straight trans man married to
the sea
uranus so ace that she doesn't
understand the question
and wishes everyone who would just stop
asking